so I try to start off nice and gently
though you will find you will find as
I'm kind of I've got the apt to kind of
in the back of my mind that's where
we're headed what happens in the AP in
any AP period and by extension at the
HSC is that questions become less about
like in a textbook you have a whole
bunch of exercises that each
individually assess a very very narrow
particular skill right but then the more
you know the more you're able to combine
different skills together and you'll get
them presented to you in the HSE as like
a single like double bound question that
has all these different elements to it
and this first one is an example of that
so normally you just be asked ok round
this just round it ok and that's where
the question ends but you can see from
here I move on to a second thing so
we'll talk about I'm carry-forward
errors in a second but let's look at the
answer I've ran into two significant
figures now one of the tricky things
about numbers like this is that when you
think about these zeros here they're not
giving you any meaningful information ok
so as opposed to decimal places where
it's just like look just tell me where
that is and then count from their
significant figures you have to count
from the first number that's meaningful
which in this case is the five okay so
you look at that five you say well that
guy's significant you look at the next
one and say okay that's the last digit I
can have which will keep significant I
better work out whether it should go up
or stay where it is and from there you
can see okay the six is going to mean is
going to go on can you see how i went
from that first rounding off step to the
second one frequently scientific
notation is given either to two or three
significant figures and so I opted for
to hear how did I know is 10 to the
negative 3 how did I how did I work that
out
okay good so I can think about like the
decimal point I wanted to end up there
you see that okay because we know
scientific notation has two things that
makes it scientific notation were the
two things remember talk about the
second number okay so yet the first
number it's gotta be between 1 and 10 so
that's why you gotta have 5.1 you can't
have 51 or 0.5 1 and then you have the
decimal point right so you can see where
i want the decimal point to end and it
moves one two three times to the right
the numbers getting smaller ok so that's
why i put 10 to the negative 3 okay
let's have a look at the equation here
are my two answers now I've kind of
disguised what working took me from the
given line to my first line can you tell
me can you look and diagnose what's
going on underneath I've rearranged them
things right what have they done to both
sides let's just think about the wise
what am I done with the wise okay so you
can see they're all wise on the left
hand side before and now there aren't
any more now we've talked about this
before maybe you it's really ingrained
in you that the way you'd say that you
would describe it is I moved the 3y to
the right-hand side I think it's
probably better to say it like this i
subtracted 3y from both sides okay
you're keeping things balanced it's an
equation after all okay that's why there
are no more wise left on the left
remaining on the left what I do with the
numbers what did I do to both sides yeah
very good I added 14 to cancer that with
that minus 14 that [ __ ] to 14 that
gives me this next line and then I just
had to divide by two okay happy times it
didn't matter which format you gave the
question the answer in that was no part
of the question so whatever your persons
given either those is fine okay now here
another double bound question i'll let
you scrutinize my working now do you see
why what makes this well actually it's
kind of triple-barreled isn't it I look
at the question
and see what it's asking of you okay I
hope a lot of you if you're looking at
someone's working have underlined
important things can someone tell me
what the important information is so the
first important piece of information is
you have to calculate interest now
that's sneaky whoever wrote these
questions was very sneaky because it's
compound interest right compound but you
have a look if you can't remember you've
got the formula data street there the
compound interest formula doesn't just
give you interest look I've even written
it out character for character bear what
does it give you what's the subject of
the boiler yeah it's the whole mount
that's why it's a for about okay the
total value of whatever you're learning
is okay so therefore you can have to do
this extra work over here I'll get to
shortly what other Peter information in
the question are important okay very
good so a lot of you just missed that it
was quarterly so you said okay eight
percent five years so as a consequence
you're going to be missing these two
things here okay can you see by the way
just for my own sake I could have done
zero point zero eight divided by four
and I could have done five times for I
could have done them in my hair but I
like having them there because I'm
trying to communicate to the marker
which at the moment is you guys for me
that I I know where those numbers come
from zero point zero didn't plug that
out of nowhere a divided by 4 because
there's less interest each time and I
had to multiply by 4 because there's
more compounding periods okay so you
work it out you subtract to get your
interest and there's your number okay
maybe you want to give a mark for the
calculation of the actual amount and
then another mark for the calculation of
the interest question
like literally and I don't like actually
like I dislike a 12 x 12 x a quarter
yeah okay so if you did that 12 times a
quarter sorry a quarter what you're
working out is how many months there are
in a corner because that's that's where
the 12 comes in yeah like what you've
just worked out 3 is how many months
there are in a quarter but I'm I'm not
that interested in how many months there
are I'm interested in how many quarters
there are because that's how often in
compound so that's why you can if you
have a look at my working you see my
working 12 never appears because I never
think about months does that make sense
yeah that'll change things okay let's
have a look at this driving question
hands up who got this one right hands up
hands up straight so I can see okay
thank your hands down it's a decent
number thank you hands down
okay all right this is a good cook can I
pour Zevon for a second i stood lots of
questions to go through so i'll hold
that is most of the discussion for now
if that's okay but just this particular
question is very very relevant because
um it comes out of the question and it's
a great thing to ask about so the
question was look it says one decimal
place in the question right and you
notice have a look at my working do you
notice the doctor dots you can see over
here on the you know on the right hand
side now what's going on there is that
my calculator I can see from my
calculator which is gone up so much
easier that um I don't get a nice neat
answer I get all these extra decimal
places they make a difference to me um
the question was like well if it's one
decimal place like instead of 9.43 can i
write 9.4 will it make a difference ok
now I'm going to get you to answer that
question for me by looking at my working
look at my work and carefully and tell
me by look I'll even give you a clue
look at this line this is the line that
tells you whether that 0.03 whether it's
going to make a difference or not what
do you reckon the answer is yes why is
it that this line tells you yes it's
going to make a difference what's it
what's important in this line that means
hey don't chop off that 0.03 you want to
make sure it's still there when you do
this one of the closes it is answer to
one decimal place it doesn't say every
time you get a number and off along the
way right so that's one clue let me draw
this for you and maybe you see if you
remember this if you get like some
random polygon okay and then I give you
a whole bunch of measurements like this
um da da da you get all these numbers
here and if I asked you for the
perimeter ok a natural question that I
could ask you under mm one would be can
you tell me what the greatest possible
error in calculating the perimeter
might be okay now look look this is this
is what's so great about this course you
don't need any words to tell you what's
going on to you just look at one of
these measurements suppose I hit all
rest of the diagram and i just gave you
that what's the greatest possible error
think about it I think the answer is 5
centimeters or 0.05 meters the way I
know is because I've got it accurate to
one decimal place so therefore I could
go up or down half of that one that's
nice which is 2.05 now but hold on a
second right I don't just have one
measurement I have one two three four
five measurements right so now sue me
out to the entire shape if I'm
calculating the perimeter now what's the
greatest possible error yeah it's not
it's not five centimeters it's five
centimeters five more times it's 25
centimeters does that make sense now I
think I can't come back to our working
over here if I have an error of 0.03
look at how many times that error is
going to be x that air is going to get
39 times bigger because that's what I
had to do in this line ok so I'm going
to expect that on make a difference to
me in my decimal places okay probably oh
wait this would be a you if you were
lucky this would be a to mark question
and you didn't miss one of them